- But anyway, I heard that
there was another Nico Santos
as well, right?
- There is.
He's a singer.
There's this Nico Santos from Germany
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Nico] Yes! He's a singer.
He's (stuttering) cute right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Don't tell my boyfriend.
- (laughing) Don't tell my boyfriend.
- It never work if the same name.
- (laughing) Yes. Exactly.
But people on social media
always tag me instead of him,
and they're just like "I love your song.
"Your song this. Your song that."
- So this happens to you too?
- [Nico] Regularly!
So I just started like,
messing with the fan,
with his fans.
- Yeah good, good.
- I'm just like you know that song
was about the time I was really down.
(audience laughing)
And it was about that
time I shoplifted the ham.
(audience laughing)
And stuck it down my pants
and walked out the store.
So thank you for supporting my music.
- (laughing) Thank you
for supporting my music!
- But he knows about me apparently,
and he's like "I think
you're really funny."
(audience laughing)
- [Abigail] Oh my gosh, I love that!
- Yeah and there's apparently
like a Superstore billboard in Berlin.
It's like I've seen the billboard.
And I was like "Oh okay."
- Oh my gosh.
- As long as you support.
- I see a
- [Kelly] I see a podcast.
- Yeah.
(all) Yeah.
- I'll do a duet.
- [Kelly] You're hilarious.
(audience laughing)
You've already done it,
you just didn't know.
- [Nico] Exactly!
- Loved your duet!
(laughing)